Have you ever tried BBQ on BBQ? Picture this. Freshly prepared crispy seasoned chicken that's tossed in a smoky BBQ glaze and topped with a creamy BBQ sauce. Can't picture it? Well you can try it now at Tim's. Get our new BBQ crispy chicken loaded bowls and wraps for a limited time. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Please note that the names of several individuals mentioned in this episode have been changed. Fiona Kennedy brought her car to a stop before the red light. It was Monday, November 15, 1971, and the 18 year old was enjoying a day off from work. After spending the morning shopping, Fiona was heading home along Northern Lights Boulevard, a main thoroughfare in the Alaskan city of Anchorage. As she waited at the traffic lights, Fiona casually scanned her surroundings and happened to lock eyes with the driver of the car next to hers. He was an unremarkable white man aged in his 30s with short hair hidden under a fluorescent orange baseball cap. A large pair of thick rimmed eyeglasses framed his cold stare. In an effort to break the awkward exchange, Fiona smiled at the man, then focused her attention back on the road ahead.
你尝过烧烤味的烧烤吗？试想一下：外焦里嫩、调味十足的新鲜鸡肉，裹上一层烟熏烧烤釉，上面再浇上一层浓郁的烧烤酱。想象不出来？没关系，你现在就可以去蒂姆餐厅尝尝。即日起至限时，购买我们全新的烧烤脆皮鸡碗和卷饼。我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关机密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。请注意，本集中提及的几位个人的名字已被更改。菲奥娜·肯尼迪在红灯前停下了车。那是1971年11月15日星期一，这位18岁的姑娘正享受着工作日的一天假。度过了一个上午的购物后，菲奥娜沿着安克雷奇阿拉斯加市的主干道北极光大道开车回家。当她在红绿灯前等待时，菲奥娜随意地扫视着周围，碰巧与旁边车的司机四目相对。他是一个不起眼的30多岁白人男子，留着短发，戴着一顶荧光橙色棒球帽。一副厚框大眼镜衬托着他冰冷的目光。为了打破尴尬的交流，菲奥娜向那名男子微笑了笑，然后把注意力重新集中在前面的道路上。
The light turned green and Fiona took off, thinking little of the meaningless though somewhat uncomfortable interaction. Around 10 minutes later, Fiona arrived at her apartment complex on Lowest Drive. After carrying her shopping up the two flights of stairs to her place, she started to run a bath. All of a sudden, there was a knock at her front door. Fiona wrapped her naked body in a towel and went to answer it. Standing before her was the man from the stoplight. Up close, Fiona could see his pockmarked face permanently scarred from a bout of severe acne. The man explained that he was looking for someone who lived in the complex.
绿灯亮了，菲奥娜开车出发了，对这次毫无意义但又有点令人不舒服的互动没有多想。大约10分钟后，菲奥娜到达了她位于最低大道的公寓大楼。把采购的东西拎上两层楼梯回到住处后，她开始放洗澡水。突然，前门传来敲门声。菲奥娜用毛巾裹住赤裸的身体去开门。站在她面前的是红绿灯处的那名男子。近距离看，菲奥娜可以看到他那布满痘坑的脸，由于严重痤疮发作而永久留下了疤痕。这名男子解释说，他在找一个住在这个小区的人。
Noticing a phone book on a table just inside Fiona's apartment, he asked if he could come in and look at it for a second. Fiona agreed, and the man absentmindedly flipped through the pages, remarking that the number he was looking for must have been unlisted. Then he started making small talk. He said he was new in Anchorage, didn't know many people, and asked if Fiona would like to go on a date with him. No thanks, she replied, explaining that she was engaged. The man left soon after. One week later, Fiona woke early to drive some friends to work. At 5.15am, she wandered down to her car and took off.
注意到菲奥娜公寓里的一张桌子上放着一本电话簿，他问是否可以进来借看一秒钟。菲奥娜同意了，男子心不在焉地翻着书页，并评论说他找的号码一定是没有登记的。然后他开始闲聊。他说他是刚来安克雷奇的，认识的人不多，并问菲奥娜愿不愿意和他约会。不用了谢谢，她回答说，并解释自己已经订婚了。男子不久后便离开了一周后，菲奥娜一早醒来送几个朋友去上班。早上5点15分，她晃悠着走到车前并出发了。
It was still dark when Fiona returned home a short while later. For a brief moment, her car's headlights illuminated a man in a fluorescent orange cap as he darted behind a neighbouring property out of sight. Fiona parked in the carport, and upon stepping out of her vehicle, came face to face with the barrel of a revolver. Holding tightly onto its grip was the man she had smiled at a week earlier at the stoplight. He threatened to shoot Fiona if she made a sound. Unable to contain her fear, Fiona let out a scream. The man pushed his gun into her back and again threatened her to stay quiet. We're going someplace we can be alone, he revealed, as he led Fiona towards the street.
不久后菲奥娜开车回家时天色依然昏暗。短暂的一瞬间，她汽车的车灯照亮了一个戴着荧光橙色帽子的男子，他正急匆匆地躲到邻近房产后面消失在视线之外。菲奥娜把车停在车棚里，刚从车里下来，就迎面碰上了一支左轮手枪的枪管。紧紧握着枪柄的正是她一周前在红绿灯处对之微笑的男子。他威胁菲奥娜说如果敢出声就开枪打死她。无法遏制恐惧，菲奥娜尖叫了起来。那名男子将枪顶在她的背上，再次威胁她保持安静。我们要去一个可以独处的地方，他透露着，一边带着菲奥娜走向街道。
Suddenly, he was stopped in his tracks by the sound of a police siren. It had started in the distance, but was getting louder with each passing second. Fiona's scream had woken her roommates who ran to a window, saw her being held at gunpoint, and called 9-1-1. As police sped to the scene, the man lowered his weapon and walked off into the darkness. Fiona's gun wielding abductor Lowest Drive became a hive of police activity, as officers scoured the area for Fiona's gun-wielding abductor. Sometime after 7am, a squad car pulled up out the front of Fiona's apartment. She approached the vehicle and peered through a window into the back seat.
突然，他被一阵警笛声戛然而止。声音起初还在远处，但随着每一秒的过去变得越来越大。菲奥娜的尖叫声惊醒了她的室友，室友跑到窗前，看到她被人用枪指着，便拨打了911。当警察飞驰赶往现场时，男子放下武器，走进了黑暗中。菲奥娜持枪绑架者的最低大道成了警察活动的中心，警官们在四周搜寻菲奥娜持枪绑架者的踪迹。早上7点过后不久，一辆警车停在了菲奥娜公寓的前面。她走近车辆，透过窗户向后座张望。
That's him, she confirmed. Her abductor had been found walking the street close by and was charged with assault with a deadly weapon. He maintained that he had no recollection of the event. In a pretrial bail hearing, counsel for the defense successfully depicted their client as a hard-working and well-respected church-going family man. He was released on $2,000 bail pending a trial that was scheduled to begin in January the following year. But by late December, the man was prowling the streets of Anchorage once again, looking for his next target. In the early morning hours of Sunday December 19, Gemma Gibbs rushed across a parking lot and into the warmth of a nearby cafe. The 18-year-old was in desperate need of a hot drink to ward off Anchorage's icy winter.
是他，她确认道。她的绑架者被发现在附近的街道上闲逛，并被控持致命武器攻击罪。他坚持说自己对该事件毫无记忆。在审前保释听证会上，辩护律师成功地将他们的客户描绘成一个勤劳、备受尊敬且经常去教堂的顾家好男人。他以2,000美元保释金获释，等待定于次年1月开始的审判。但到了12月下旬，这名男子再次在安克雷奇的街头徘徊，寻找他的下一个目标。12月19日星期日的清晨，杰玛·吉布斯快步穿过停车场，走进了附近一家咖啡馆的温暖中。这位18岁的姑娘急需一杯热饮来驱散安克雷奇冰冷的冬日。
After ordering a tea, Gemma headed back outside to start the heater in her car so it would be toasty for the drive home. While doing so, she saw a silver blue Pontiac pull into a neighboring parking spot. A man emerged from the vehicle, but she paid him little attention. Once her car heater was blasting, Gemma returned to the cafe to collect her order. The male driver of the Pontiac was standing by the cafe door as if waiting for her. When Gemma approached, he blocked her path and attempted to start a conversation. It seemed like he was going to ask her something, but a stutter got the better of him and he struggled to form the words. Gemma tried to push past him, but froze when he pulled out a gun from underneath his coat.
点了一杯茶后，杰玛转身回到外面去发动汽车上的加热器，这样开车回家时就会很暖和。在此期间，她看到一辆银蓝色庞蒂克轿车开进了相邻的停车位。一名男子从车里出来，但她没有怎么注意他。当她的汽车暖气开到最大时，杰玛回到咖啡馆去取她的订单。庞蒂克的男司机正站在咖啡馆门口，仿佛在等她。当杰玛走近时，他挡住了她的去路并试图搭话。看起来他想问她点什么，但结巴让他说不出话来，他努力想组织语言。杰玛试图挤过他，但当他从外套底下掏出一把枪时，她吓僵了。
Don't scream, he warned as he forced her into his Pontiac. A passing car's headlights cut through the early morning darkness and swept over her abductor, illuminating his pockmarked face and large eyeglasses. He drove Gemma south along the Seward Highway, where the city streets gave way to snowy fields, forested hills and rugged mountain ranges. Bound by her wrists and ankles with leather shoelaces, Gemma endured a 100-mile long drive, during which she was periodically assaulted and eventually raped. She was relieved when her captor started the long journey back to Anchorage, only for him to perform a U-turn and continue heading south. Why are we going this way? Gemma asked. Her captor told her of a cabin he had taken a woman to a week prior. That's where they were going now. He drove to the expansive Cooper Lake region and turned down a secluded ancillary road that curled up a mountain.
别尖叫，他警告说，同时把她强行塞进他的庞蒂克轿车里。一辆过往汽车的车灯划破了清晨的黑暗，扫过她的绑架者，照亮了他布满痘坑的脸和大眼镜。他带着杰玛沿苏厄德公路向南行驶，那里的城市街道让位于白雪皑皑的田野、长满森林的山丘和崎岖的山脉。杰玛的手腕和脚踝被皮鞋带绑着，忍受了100英里长的车程，期间她断断续续地遭到袭击，最终被强奸。当她的绑架者开始踏上返回安克雷奇的长途跋涉时，她松了一口气，结果他却调头继续向南行驶。我们为什么要走这条路？杰玛问。她的绑架者向她讲述了一座小屋，他一周前曾带一个女人去过那里。他们现在就要去那里。他开车驶往辽阔的库珀湖地区，拐进了一条蜿蜒上山的偏僻小路。
They got a fair way up, only to discover that heavy snowfall blanketed the road ahead, making it impossible to proceed any further. Irritated, the man turned the car around. During the descent, Gemma noticed her captor eyeing the cliffside that boarded the road. She sensed he was twinging with the idea of shooting her, then throwing her into the ravine. As described in the book Fair Game by Bernard Duclos, the man abruptly hit the brakes and forced Gemma out of the car. Cocking his gun, he ordered her to start running. Gemma knew what the man would do the moment she turned her back to flee and told him she wasn't going to run, no matter what. Instead, she faced him and began begging for her life, saying everything she could think of to make him reconsider.
他们开了一段相当长的路，却发现前方道路被厚厚的积雪覆盖，根本无法继续前行。这名男子恼羞怒号地把车调头。在下山的过程中，杰玛注意到她的绑架者一直在打量路旁的悬崖。她感觉到他心里在盘算着开枪打死她，然后把她扔进峡谷。正如伯纳德·杜克罗斯在书中所描述的那样，这名男子猛地踩下刹车，强行把杰玛赶下了车。他拉起枪栓，命令她开始跑。杰玛深知只要自己一转身逃跑这名男子会做什么，便告诉他无论如何她都不会跑。相反，她面对着他开始哀求保命，说尽一切能想到的事情来让他重新考虑。
She complimented him, suggesting that they'd date and told him about her baby son. Promising she wouldn't go to the police, she offered him her name and address and that of her parents as insurance that she would keep her word. And just like that, her ordeal was over. Gemma was led back to the Pontiac. There were no more stops, just threats to ensure her compliance. By 2pm, she was returned to Anchorage, having been left a block from where her car was parked. Gemma kept her promise and didn't speak a word of her ordeal to the police. Days later, on December 23, Celia Van Zanten, known to friends and family as Beth, was hit by a thirst that only a soda could quench. It was 8.30pm and the nearby convenience store was due to close in half an hour.
她恭维他，暗示他们可以约会，并告诉他关于自己婴儿儿子的事。她承诺不会报警，并向他提供她自己以及她父母的姓名和地址，作为她会守信用的保证。就这样，她的苦难结束了。杰玛被带回庞蒂克车上。没有更多的停留，只有确保她服从的威胁。下午2点，她被送回了安克雷奇，被丢在距离她停车的地方一个街区远的地方。杰玛遵守了诺言，对警察只字未提自己的遭遇。几天后的12月23日，西莉亚·范赞滕（朋友和家人称她为贝丝）突然感到口渴，这种口渴只有苏打水才能解渴。当时是晚上8点半，附近的一家便利店半小时后就要关门了。
Beth pulled on her green, down-filled parka and rubber-soled hiking boots. Then headed out into the winter chill. It was only a short walk from her Kinnick Avenue home to the shops on Northern Lights Boulevard. Yet, Beth never returned. On Christmas Day, a nature photographer was attempting to take the perfect picture of a waterfall in the McHugh Creek Recreation Area. South of Anchorage. As he edged closer to the water, he noticed what appeared to be a mannequin halfway up the ravine. It was positioned at an odd angle and partially covered with snow.
贝丝套上她那件绿色的羽绒派克大衣和橡胶底登山靴。然后走进了冬日的寒冷中。从她位于金尼克大道的家步行到北极光大道的商店只有短短的一段路。然而，贝丝再也没有回来。圣诞节当天，一位自然摄影师正试图在麦克休溪休闲区拍摄一张完美的瀑布照片。位于安克雷奇南部。当他走近水边时，他注意到半山腰的峡谷里似乎有一个人体模特。它的摆放角度很奇怪，上面还部分覆盖着雪。
Except, it wasn't a mannequin. It was the body of a young woman. Police identified her as 18-year-old Beth Van Zanten, who had vanished from downtown Anchorage two days earlier. Beth's hands were tied behind her back with speaker wire and a gag had been placed over her mouth. Naked from the waist down, she had been sexually assaulted. And had sustained a slash across her chest from a knife used to cut open her bra. 50 or so feet above where Beth was found was a parking area. It was believed that she had either fled from her attacker into the ravine, or that he thought she had been killed.
然而，那不是人体模特。那是一具年轻女性的尸体。警方确认她是18岁的贝丝·范赞滕，她两天前在安克雷奇市中心失踪。贝丝的双手被喇叭线反绑在背后，嘴里塞着一块口塞。她腰部以下赤裸，曾遭受性侵犯。胸部曾被用来割开她胸罩的刀子划伤。在发现贝丝的上方大约50英尺处有一个停车场。据信，要么是她从袭击者手中逃到峡谷里，要么是袭击者以为她已经死了。
Stripped of her jacket and boots, Beth had faced temperatures as low as minus five degrees Fahrenheit in the days she was missing. At that time of year, Anchorage was plunged into a long darkness with less than six hours of light expected per day. Straining to trudge bound and barefoot through three feet of snow, back up the darkened slope, Beth eventually succumbed to the harsh elements and froze to death. In the darkened slope, Beth was found lying on the ground. She was found lying on the ground. In the darkened slope, Beth was found lying on the ground. She was found dead.
贝丝脱掉了夹克和靴子，在失踪的日子里面对着低至华氏零下五度的温度。每年的那个时候，安克雷奇都陷入漫长的黑暗中，预计每天的光照时间不到六小时。贝丝挣扎着被捆绑且赤脚在三英尺深的雪地里艰难跋涉，爬回黑暗的山坡上，最终没能挺过严酷的自然环境，冻死在山坡上。在黑暗的山坡上，人们发现贝丝躺在地上。她被发现躺在地上。在黑暗的山坡上，人们发现贝丝躺在地上。她被发现时已经死亡。
News of what happened to Beth Van Zanten rattled fellow Anchorage teen Gemma Gibbs. She was certain that the man who had abducted and raped her at gunpoint was also responsible for Beth's death. In order to secure her freedom, Gemma had promised never to tell the police what had happened to her. Now she realized that her silence might have enabled her attacker to assault and murder someone else. Compelled by guilt, Gemma went to the authorities and identified her assailant. It was the same man who had attempted to abduct Fiona Kennedy from her lowest drive apartment in November. Now he faced felony charges for two separate crimes, the second he committed while on bail for the first. Yet he managed to secure a deal.
贝丝·范赞滕遭遇的消息震惊了同为安克雷奇少年的杰玛·吉布斯。她确信那个持枪绑架并强奸她的男子也对贝丝的死负有责任。为了保住自由，杰玛曾承诺绝不把发生在她身上的事告诉警方。现在她意识到，她的沉默可能让她的袭击者得以去袭击和谋杀其他人。在内疚感的驱使下，杰玛前往当局指认了她的行凶者。这就是那个11月份试图从最低大道公寓绑架菲奥娜·肯尼迪的同一个男人。现在他面临着两起不同罪行的重罪指控，第二起是他因第一起保释期间犯下的。然而他却设法达成了一项协议。
He pleaded no contest to the charge of assault with a deadly weapon against Fiona. In exchange, charges relating to the abduction and rape of Gemma were dropped. From the prosecution's perspective, there just wasn't enough evidence in that case to secure a conviction. In his sentencing remarks, the judge told the man, I believe you have a serious illness that makes you extremely dangerous. But then he sentenced him to just five years in prison and added, I recommend work release for you as soon as possible so you can pursue your employment and support your family. A model prisoner, the man was released after serving only three months behind bars.
他对针对菲奥娜的持致命武器攻击罪名提出了不予抗辩。作为交换，与绑架和强奸杰玛相关的指控被撤销。从检方的角度来看，该案中根本没有足够的证据来定罪。在量刑陈述中，法官对该男子说：“我相信你患有一种严重的疾病，这让你极度危险。”但随后他判处他仅五年监禁，并补充道：“我建议你尽早获得工作假释，这样你就可以继续就业并养家糊口。”作为一名模范囚犯，该男子在服刑仅仅三个月后就获释了。
When speaking of the outcome, Gemma Gibbs remarked, It was like you're not only raped by the perpetrator, but again by the court. Although there was reasonable suspicion to believe that the same man was involved in the abduction, rape and death of Beth Vanzantin, there was no evidence to support the allegation and that case went cold. Upon his release from prison, the man returned to Anchorage, a city big and busy enough to forget his transgressions. He continued living a normal life while those aware of his history took it with a grain of salt, as the crimes didn't align with the man they knew personally. He remained married, had a second child, moved into a large house, owned three vehicles and started a successful business.
谈到这个结果时，杰玛·吉布斯评论道：“这就像你不仅被作恶者强奸了，还被法庭再次强奸了。”尽管有合理怀疑认为同一名男子参与了贝丝·范赞滕的绑架、强奸和死亡事件，但没有任何证据支持这一指控，该案也随之成了悬案。出狱后，这名男子回到了安克雷奇，一个大到足以让人遗忘他的过错的繁华城市。他继续过着正常的生活，而那些了解他历史的人则对此持保留态度，因为这些罪行与他们个人所认识的那个男人不符。他依然保持着婚姻，有了第二个孩子，搬进了一栋大房子，拥有三辆汽车并创办了一家成功的事业。
For him, it was as though nothing ever happened, but he never changed. In the year after making parole, he lured a 16-year-old girl into his car and drove her around for hours, sexually assaulting her at gunpoint. He warned her not to go to the police or else he would, quote, hunt her down. She complied with his threat. His appetite for dominance and control continued to grow. His stalking grounds primarily encompassed the downtown Anchorage, specifically an area known as the Tenderloin District. Over the years, the construction of the 800-mile-long Trans-Alaska oil pipeline had led to transient laborers rushing to the city. Organized crime followed as drug dealers and dodgy nightclub operators sought to take advantage of the sudden influx of young men with disposable incomes.
对他来说，就好像什么都没发生过一样，但他从未改变。在获得假释后的第二年，他诱骗一名16岁女孩上车并带她兜风数小时，在枪口下对其实施性侵犯。他警告她不要报警，否则他会“追杀她”。她服从了他的威胁。他对统治和控制的渴望继续增长。他的跟踪范围主要包括安克雷奇市中心，特别是被称为田德洛伊区的一个地区。多年来，800英里长的跨阿拉斯加输油管道的建设导致大量临时劳工涌入该市。随后有组织犯罪接踵而至，毒贩和可疑的夜总会经营者试图利用这群拥有可支配收入的年轻男子的突然涌入。
They set up in the Tenderloin District and ran various bars, adult stores and strip clubs. Police were frequently called out to the area to deal with fights and robberies. The women who worked there were particularly vulnerable. Despite being married, the men would prowl the Tenderloin District looking for sex workers. One such occasion occurred in October 1975. He propositioned a dancer at the Kit Kat Club, showing her a wad of cash and asking to have some fun. She agreed. That night, he drove her to the Chugach State Park east of Anchorage and raped her at gunpoint.
他们在田德洛伊区安营扎寨，经营着各种酒吧、成人商店和脱衣舞俱乐部。警方经常被叫到该地区处理打架斗殴和抢劫事件。在那里工作的女性尤其脆弱。尽管已婚，这名男子还是会在田德洛伊区四处寻找性工作者。其中一次发生在1975年10月。他向吉特卡特俱乐部的一名舞女搭讪，向她展示了一叠现金并要求“找点乐子”。她同意了。那天晚上，他把她开车带到安克雷奇东部的库加奇州立公园，并在枪口下强奸了她。
He ultimately released her and, for personal reasons, she chose not to file charges. She did, however, give his vehicle's license plate number to a rape crisis center, which led to his identification. The case was handed over to the Alaska State Troopers, but without the survivor's assistance, their options were limited. A trooper did contact the man's parole officer to inform him of the incident. When confronted, the man admitted to being with the woman, but said her was only ever at date. Then she started demanding money that he refused to pay, which led her to, quote, get mad and holler rape. The parole officer wasn't convinced by his story, but there was nothing more he could do.
他最终释放了她，出于个人原因，她选择不提起指控。不过，她确实将他车辆的车牌号给了一个强情危机中心，这导致了他的身份被确认。案件移交给阿拉斯加州骑警，但在没有幸存者协助的情况下，他们的选择有限。一名骑警确实联系了该男子的假释官，将该事件告知了他。面对质问，该男子承认曾与该女子在一起，但坚称“这只是一次约会”。然后她开始索要他拒绝支付的钱，这导致她“发火并大喊强奸”。假释官对他的故事并不买账，但他也无能为力了。
That was until April the following year. That month, the parole officer appeared in court to testify against the man after he was caught stealing a chainsaw from a superstore. The officer spoke at length about the abduction of the dancer from the Kit Kat Club, while highlighting the defendant's increasingly violent sexual behavior. He went so far as to doubt that the man would cooperate and respond to therapy now, and was of the opinion that he be locked up. Given the Kit Kat Club incident hadn't been verified by the legal process, the presiding judge decided not to take the parole officer's testimony into consideration. He did, however, listen intently when the defendant politely read out a statement to the court. He spoke of his wife and two children, saying they would be made to suffer if he was imprisoned, and he wanted to stay out of jail to support them. He concluded,
直到第二年四月。那个月，假释官出庭作证指控这名男子，此前他因在一家大卖场偷窃链锯被抓。假释官详细讲述了基特卡特俱乐部舞者被绑架的经过，同时强调了被告日益暴力的性行为。他甚至怀疑该男子现在是否还会配合并对治疗做出反应，并认为应该将其关押起来。鉴于基特卡特俱乐部的事件未经法律程序核实，审判长决定不予采纳假释官的证词。不过，当被告礼貌地向法庭宣读一份声明时，他还是仔细聆听了。他谈到了自己的妻子和两个孩子，说如果他被判入狱，他们将会遭受痛苦，他希望留在狱外来养家糊口。他最后总结道，
I want to live a life that's acceptable to society and to myself. After praising the man for speaking so eloquently, the judge sentenced him to five years. The man appealed this decision, and in a written opinion on the case submitted August 1978, the Supreme Court of Alaska said that prior to the chainsaw theft, the man had conducted his life in a normal manner. Quote, He has maintained steady employment, been a good provider, and has earned the reputation of a hard worker and a respectable member of the community. According to the book Fair Game, the defense sought the input of a psychologist, who concluded that their client was markedly disturbed, antisocial, paranoid by nature, and had a relatively weaker ego. In examining his past behaviors to the present day, it was noted that the man's personality had disintegrated to a highly psychotic level, or high schizophrenia scale, high manic scale, and high antisocial scale, with the psychologist adding, quote, There's some narcissism and a magical thinking involved in this also.
我想过一种为社会和自己所接受的生活。法官称赞该男子言辞流畅后，判处了他五年监禁。该男子对这一决定提起上诉，阿拉斯加最高法院在1978年8月提交的一份关于该案的书面意见中表示，在偷窃链锯之前，该男子一直以正常方式生活。引述：他一直保持着稳定的工作，是一个好的顶梁柱，并赢得了努力工作者和社区受人尊敬成员的声誉。根据《公平游戏》一书，辩护方寻求了一位心理学家的意见，该心理学家得出结论，他们的客户明显受到干扰，反社会，天生偏执，且自我意识相对较弱。在审查他从过去到现在的行为时，人们注意到该男子的性格已经瓦解到高度精神病的水平，或者说高精神分裂症量表、高狂躁量表和高反社会量表，心理学家补充道，引述：其中也包含一些自恋和奇幻思维。
The defense scrapped this finding and sourced a second, more desirous opinion. This second doctor diagnosed their client as suffering a variant of a manic depressive disorder known as a bipolar effective disorder, wherein he had poor control over his impulses due to mood and energy upswings. His kleptomania was a result of this disorder. The doctor maintained that the man was responding well to therapy and medication, and felt there would be no more issues if he continued this routine. The appellate judges agreed that the defendant's antisocial behavior was a mental health issue that could be treated. They ordered him to be released on probation at the end of that month. Even though the courts were absolutely convinced that the man would commit additional crimes without the implementation of a medication and therapy regime, administrative blunders meant that he was returned to society without any court ordered guidelines, mandates, or supervision.
辩护方放弃了这一调查结果，并寻找了第二种更合心意的意见。这位第二位医生诊断他们的客户患有一种躁郁症的变体，被称为双相情感障碍，由于情绪和精力的起伏，他对冲动的控制力较差。他的偷窃癖正是这种疾病的结果。这位医生坚称，该男子对治疗和药物反应良好，并认为如果他继续这种常规，就不会再有任何问题。上诉法官同意被告的反社会行为是可以治疗的心理健康问题。他们下令在该月底释放他并进行缓刑。尽管法院绝对相信，如果没有实施药物和治疗方案，该男子将会犯下更多的罪行，但行政失误意味着他重返社会时没有任何法院下令的指导方针、授权或监督。
The following year on Sunday, October 14, 1979, the man sat alone at a club called Ambers in downtown Anchorage with beer in hand, watching a young woman dance on a nearby tabletop. Their eyes met and he asked if they could meet later. A stutter fragmented his words, but his intentions were clear the moment he pulled out a roll of money. The dancer, Judy Russell, accepted his offer. She'd be off in 20 minutes. We'll meet outside, he said. Look for a gold camper. Upon leaving Ambers, Judy spotted a gold-colored pickup truck parked nearby.
第二年，即1979年10月14日星期日，这名男子独自坐在安克雷奇市中心一家名为安伯斯的俱乐部里，手里拿着啤酒，看着一个年轻女子在附近的桌面上跳舞。他们的目光交汇了，他问他们是否可以稍后见面。口吃让他的话语支离破碎，但他掏出一卷钱的那一刻，他的意图已经很明显了。舞者朱迪·拉塞尔接受了他的提议。她20分钟后下班。我们在外面见，他说。找一辆金色的露营车。离开安伯斯后，朱迪发现附近停着一辆金色的皮卡车。
The vehicle, which had a camper attachment in its cargo bed, had seen better days. The man from the club was waiting for her. She followed him into the camper, where he pulled out a .357 Magnum revolver. Judy was forced to strip naked as her hands were bound with snare wire. She was threatened to keep quiet, but Judy screamed constantly. Dreading someone would hear her and contact police, the man leapt out of the camper and rushed to the front of his truck, throwing himself behind the wheel. He sped towards the Glen Highway, hoping to reach the expansive wilderness that framed the northern part of the city before authorities caught up. Little did he realize that behind him, Judy had escaped her restraints.
这辆货厢带有露营车附件的车辆已经破旧不堪。俱乐部的那个人在等她。她跟着他进了露营车，他在那里掏出了一把.357马格南左轮手枪。朱迪被迫脱光衣服，双手被套索线捆绑。她受到威胁要保持安静，但朱迪一直在尖叫。由于害怕有人听到她并联系警察，该男子跳出露营车，冲到卡车前方，扑向方向盘。他加速驶向格伦公路，希望在当局赶到之前到达构筑城市北部边缘的广阔荒野。他没有意识到，在他身后的朱迪已经挣脱了束缚。
When he heard her pounding on the camper's walls, he started to panic. Slamming the brakes, he rushed around his truck to confront her, only to discover that Judy had locked the camper's doors. She quickly crawled into the cab of the truck and locked the doors there too, just as the man appeared outside the driver's side window. It was rolled partway down. The man reached in and grabbed desperately at the door's lock. Judy leant over and wound the window up, trapping his arm. Her sheer terror was matched by his unbridled fury. He smashed the window to free his arm, unlocked the door, grabbed Judy and pulled her bound and naked onto the ground.
当他听到她猛烈捶打露营车壁的声音时，他开始惊慌失措。他猛踩刹车，急忙绕到卡车前去质问她，却发现朱迪已经锁上了露营车的门。她迅速爬进卡车驾驶室，也将门锁上了，就在这时，那个男人出现在驾驶员侧的车窗外。车窗只摇下来了一部分。男人伸手进去，拼命抓着车门锁。朱迪俯身把车窗摇上去，夹住了他的手臂。她极度的恐惧与他肆无忌惮的愤怒交织在一起。他砸碎车窗抽出手臂，打开车门锁，抓住朱迪，把赤身裸体且被绑着的她拖到了地上。
Judy refused to give in. Scrambling to her feet, she broke out in a sprint. Her captor chased her for several blocks before he gave up and returned to his pickup. Lucky for him, Judy wasn't able to identify him to the police, so he got away with it. But that didn't stop him from trying again. Later that same month, he managed to reach the wilderness outside the city as planned. This time, his captive was a 16-year-old girl he had picked up outside a movie theater. He intended to rape her, but when she revealed that she was homeless and hadn't eaten for two days, he let her go.
朱迪拒绝屈服。她跌跌撞撞地站起来，开始狂奔。绑架者追了她好几个街区，直到放弃并返回他的皮卡车。幸运的是，朱迪没能向警方认出他，所以他逃脱了法律的制裁。但这并没有阻止他再次尝试。同年晚些时候，他按照计划成功来到了城市外面的荒野。这一次，他的俘虏是一个他在电影院外接载的16岁女孩。他本打算强奸她，但当她透露自己无家可归且已经两天没吃东西时，他放了她。
This would be a rare and final moment of humanity. Later that fall, he wouldn't be so kind. Annie wandered downtown Anchorage in blue jeans, a sweater, a fur trimmed brown leather jacket and a pair of high-heeled red ankle boots. It was the fall of 1979, and although her ensemble helped ward off the crisp weather that befell Alaska that time of year, it also acted as a work uniform of sorts. Many of the young women employed in Anchorage's infamously rough Tenderloin District wore similar attire. It let male passers-by know that they were sex workers. Annie climbed into the gold pickup truck that was waiting nearby and settled into the passenger seat. Its driver was a white man of average height and build, with short brown hair and a pockmarked face.
这将是他罕见且最后的一丝人性。那年秋天晚些时候，他不会再这么手软了。安妮穿着蓝色牛仔裤、一件毛衣、一件镶毛边的棕色皮夹克和一双高跟红色短靴，在安克雷奇市中心游荡。那是1979年的秋天，尽管她的装扮有助于抵御阿拉斯加那个季节特有的清冷天气，但它某种程度上也充当了一种工作制服。许多在安克雷奇臭名昭著的艰难红灯区工作的年轻女性都穿着类似的服装。这让过往的男性行人知道她们是性工作者。安妮钻进了停在附近的一辆金色皮卡车，并在副驾驶座上坐了下来。驾驶员是一个中等身高和体型的白人男子，留着短棕色头发，脸上满是麻子。
He said he was going to take Annie to his home, and she agreed to this plan, until she realized they were heading away from the city towards the wilderness beyond. Nervously, Annie asked him to drive her back to Anchorage. He assured her that they were going to another safe location, but she didn't believe him. The atmosphere in the truck grew increasingly tense. As detailed in the book Fair Game, the man reassured Annie that he was only going to drive a little further. Well, I'm not, she snapped. The man suddenly pulled out a gun. You do exactly as I say, he warned, and you won't get hurt.
他说他要把安妮带回自己家，安妮也同意了这个计划，直到她意识到他们正驶离城市，朝远处的荒野驶去。安妮紧张地要求他开车送她回安克雷奇。他向她保证他们要去另一个安全的地方，但她不相信他。卡车里的气氛变得越来越紧张。正如书中所详述的那样，这个男人安慰安妮说他只需再开一小段路。"嗯，我可不这么想。"她没好气地说。男人突然掏出一枪。"我让你做什么你就得做什么，"他警告说，"这样你才不会受伤。"
He turned off the Glen Highway and onto a Clutner Lake Road, a long scenic stretch named after the large body of water had frames. Then, he drove down one of the many secondary tracks that branched off the main road, heading deeper into the isolated surrounds. Seasonal rain, coupled with melted glacial runoff, had turned this alternate route into a muddy swamp. The wheels of his truck sunk into the sludge, until they couldn't move any further. There was a winch on the back of his vehicle that could haul them out, but he would need the help of his captive. The man convinced Annie to unravel the cable and sort things outside, while he remained behind the wheel. With great effort, the winch successfully pulled the pickup out of the mud trap. The man pressed his foot to the accelerator, and the vehicle lurched forward.
他驶离了格伦高速公路，拐上了克卢特纳湖路，这是一条以大型水体命名的风景优美的长路。然后，他开进了一条从主路分叉出来的许多次要小路之一，向偏僻的四周更深处驶去。季节性降雨加上融化的冰川径流，使这条备用路线变成了一片泥泞的沼泽。他的卡车车轮陷入了烂泥中，直到无法再动弹。他的车后面有一个绞盘可以把他们拉出来，但他需要他的俘虏的帮忙。男人说服安妮解开缆绳并在外面整理东西，而他则留在方向盘后面。费了很大力气，绞盘成功地把皮卡从泥坑里拉了出来。男人猛踩油门，车子向前冲去。
Stay put, he yelled at Annie, as he drove further down the road to look for a spot to turn around so he could collect her on the return. Realising this was her one chance at escape, Annie edged towards the surrounding woods before breaking out into a sprint. The man slammed the brakes, cut the engine, leapt from the truck, and took off after her. Annie's high heels slid into the mud, allowing him to close in quickly and grab her by the hair. In the ensuing scuffle, she managed to reach into her purse and pull out a large, black-handled buckknife. She swung it in his direction, but he pried it from her grasp before she was able to cause him any injury. Forcing Annie to the ground, the man overpowered and restrained her. She begged, don't kill me, don't kill me.
待在原地，他对安妮大喊，同时开车向前驶去，寻找可以掉头的地方以便在回程时接她。意识到这是自己逃跑的唯一机会，安妮挪向周围的树林，然后突然狂奔起来。那男子猛踩刹车，熄火，从卡车上跳下来，朝着她追去。安妮的高跟鞋陷入泥地，这让他迅速拉近了距离并一把抓住了她的头发。在随后的挣扎中，她设法把手伸进钱包，掏出一把带黑色手柄的大型巴克折刀。她挥刀向他刺去，但他趁她还没来得及伤害他之前就把刀从她手中夺走了。男子将安妮按倒在地，将其制服并控制住。她哀求道，别杀我，别杀我。
He responded calmly, that he wasn't going to kill her. In the following year of 1980, two power plant employees were carrying out works along Lake Eklutna Road. While concentrating on a power line, the pair noticed some disturbed earth nearby, a shallow grave. It contained a severely decomposed female body. Marks on her bones revealed that she had been viciously stabbed in the back. She was dressed in jeans, a brown leather fur-trimmed coat, and red high-heeled boots. An outfit that indicated to local police officers that the woman had likely been a sex worker from the nearby city of Anchorage. Identifying her through physical features alone was impossible due to the state of her remains.
他平静地回答说，他并不打算杀她。在接下来的1980年，两名发电厂员工在埃克卢特纳湖路沿线进行施工。当两人专注于一处电路线时，注意到附近有一些翻动过的泥土，那是一个浅浅的坟墓。里面有一具高度腐烂的女尸。她骨头上的痕迹显示，她曾被残忍地刺伤背部。她身穿牛仔裤、一件带有毛皮饰边的棕色皮大衣和红色高跟鞋。这身打扮向当地警官表明，这名女子很可能是来自附近安克雷奇市的一名性工作者。由于遗骸的状态，仅通过外貌特征来辨认她的身份是不可能的。
An autopsy revealed that the victim was killed the previous year. She was 16 to 25 years old and between 4 foot 11 to 5 foot 3 inches tall. She was likely white, but possibly had Native American heritage, as suggested by some pieces of Native American-style jewellery scattered near her remains. It was unclear how exactly she'd ended up in the vicinity of Lake Eklutna. The area where she was found was so remote that it was only frequented by the power plant employees or the occasional hunter. Anchorage Police created a facial reconstruction profile of the murdered woman and printed it on posters that they plastered throughout the city. Yet, no one came forward to identify her. They dubbed their unknown victim after the place where she was discovered.
尸检显示，这名受害者是在前一年被杀害的。她年龄在16到25岁之间，身高在4英尺11英寸到5英尺3英寸之间。她很可能是白人，但也可能拥有美洲原住民血统，因为她的遗骸附近散落着一些美洲原住民风格的首饰。目前还不清楚她究竟是如何来到埃克卢特纳湖附近的。她被发现的地方极其偏僻，只有发电厂员工或偶尔的猎人光顾。安克雷奇警方制作了这名被谋杀女性的面部重建拼图，并印在海报上，贴满了整个城市。然而，没有人前来辨认她的身份。他们以发现她的地点来命名这位身份不明的受害者。
Eklutna Rani In May that same year, Joanna Messina was standing on the docks that overlooked the picturesque Seward Boat Harbour. Stretched out before her were the icy and clear glacial waters of Resurrection Bay, framed by the snow-capped mountains that define the southern coast of Alaska. Joanna was not alone. Keeping her company as always was her loyal and protective German Shepherd dog, who had travelled with her all the way from New York. Joanna was a nurse who had abruptly left her old life behind, hitching rides across the country until she wound up over the Canada-United States border and in the port city of Seward. Though only she knew the reasons behind her sudden move, it was suspected that Joanna sought to take up work in one of the state's many factories caning food. This plan didn't work out and Joanna took up sex work to make ends meet.
埃克卢特纳·拉尼。同年五月，乔安娜·梅西那正站在俯瞰风景如画的苏厄德船坞的码头上。展现在她眼前的是复活湾清澈冰冷的冰川水，四周是被白雪皑皑的山脉环绕，这些山峰正是阿拉斯加南部海岸的标志。乔安娜并非孤身一人。一如既往陪伴着她的是她那忠诚且具有保护欲的德国牧羊犬，这只狗一路陪着她从纽约来到了这里。乔安娜是一名护士，她突然抛下了旧生活，一路搭便车横跨整个国家，直到穿过加拿大和美国的边境，来到了港口城市苏厄德。虽然只有她自己知道她突然搬家的原因，但人们猜测乔安娜是想在该州众多食品罐头厂之一寻找工作。这个计划没有成功，乔安娜便开始从事性工作以维持生计。
As she watched the water lapping the docks, the petite 24-year-old with thick, urban-coloured hair caught the eye of a nearby man. Joanna noticed his attention and flashed him a smile. The man approached her and initiated some friendly chit chat before asking if she would join him for dinner. Ever since she had arrived in Seward, Joanna had been doing it tough. She'd recently been kicked out of the boarding house where she had initially settled, causing her to pitch a tent at the state campgrounds. Homeless, broke and unemployed, she took the man up on his offer. The pair headed to a nearby restaurant where they continued their conversation. Everything was going well until Joanna, seemingly misreading her male companion's intentions, propositioned him, saying,
正当她看着水波拍打码头时，这位身材娇小、拥有浓密都市发色、年仅24岁的年轻女子引起了附近一名男子的注意。乔安娜注意到了他的目光，向他微微一笑。那男子向她走去，主动进行了一番友好的闲聊，然后问她是否愿意和他一起共进晚餐。自从来到苏厄德以来，乔安娜的日子一直过得很艰难。她最近刚被她最初落脚的寄宿公寓赶了出来，导致她不得不在州立露营地搭起帐篷。她无家可归、身无分文且失业，于是接受了那名男子的邀请。两人前往附近的一家餐厅，继续他们的交谈。一切都很顺利，直到乔安娜似乎误解了这位男伴的意图，向他主动搭讪说，
We could have a real nice time if you have any money. In an instant, the man's mood soured. He didn't realise Joanna was a sex worker and was irritated to think that their connection was strictly business. He masked his feelings and coked Joanna and her German shepherd into his gold camper pickup. The man drove north along the Seward Highway, which eventually reached the city of Anchorage, 127 miles away. He only got 13 miles out of Seward before pulling over by the Snow River. It was there, in the quiet shadows of spruce trees and jagged mountains, that an argument broke out between the pair. Joanna believed the man had taken her to a discrete location beyond the city lights to engage her services.
如果你有钱的话，我们可以过一段非常美好的时光。转瞬间，那男子的情绪恶化了。他没有意识到乔安娜是一名性工作者，并对他们的关系纯粹是生意感到恼火。他掩饰了自己的情绪，将乔安娜和她的德国牧羊犬哄上了他的金色露营皮卡。那男子沿着苏厄德公路向北行驶，最终到达了127英里外的安克雷奇市。他才刚开出苏厄德13英里，就在雪河旁停下了车。正是在那里，在云杉树和参差不奇的山脉的寂静阴影下，两人之间爆发了一场争吵。乔安娜认为这名男子把她带到了远离城市灯光的偏僻地点来提供服务。
Now, he was seemingly backing out of the idea and Joanna, realising she'd travelled all this way for nothing, ordered him to take her back to Seward. His temper rising, the man ordered Joanna out of the cab and into the camper compartment of his pickup. As detailed in fair game, the man barked at Joanna, He is all your worth, before tossing $5 at her. He then launched himself at Joanna, who managed to fight him off and escape out into the cold dark. She ran, but he quickly caught up and hit her hard with a 22 magnum revolver. Joanna fell to the ground. Tears streamed down her face as her hands curled around her wounded head.
现在，他似乎在打退堂鼓，而乔安娜意识到自己大老远跑来却白跑了一趟，便命令他把她送回苏厄德。男子的脾气上来了，命令乔安娜下车，并进入他皮卡的露营车厢。正如在《公平游戏》中详细描述的那样，这名男子对乔安娜大吼，他只值这么多，同时向她扔了5美元。接着，他向乔安娜扑了过去，而乔安娜奋力反抗并逃入了寒冷黑暗的夜色中。她拼命奔跑，但他很快追了上来，用一把.22口径马格南左轮手枪狠狠地击中了她。乔安娜倒在地上。泪水顺着她的脸庞流淌，她的双手紧紧护着受伤的头部。
With fierce strength, she threw herself at her attacker, clawing and screaming at him. The man shot Joanna twice, killing her. He then rummaged through her belongings, mostly camping gear, and wrapped her in a sleeping bag. Dragging the body to a nearby gravel pit, he let it roll into the crevice before pushing in some sand and rocks to conceal it. As he returned to his truck, the man realized Joanna's German shepherd was still inside. He shot the dog to ensure it wouldn't lead anyone to its owner's remains. Then he dumped its body and Joanna's belongings in the woodland adjacent to where Joanna lay covered in the pit. Before returning to Anchorage, he threw his revolver into the Snow River.
她爆发出惊人的力量，扑向袭击者，抓挠并尖叫着。那男子向乔安娜开了两枪，将她杀害。随后，他在她的随身物品（主要是露营装备）中翻找了一番，把她包裹在睡袋里。他将尸体拖到一个附近的砂石坑，让尸体滚入缝隙，然后推了一些沙子和岩石将其掩埋。当他回到卡车时，那男子发现乔安娜的德国牧羊犬还在里面。他开枪打死了这只狗，以确保它不会把任何人引向其主人的遗骸。接着，他将狗的尸体和乔安娜的随身物品丢弃在乔安娜被掩埋的砂石坑附近的树林里。在返回安克雷奇之前，他把左轮手枪扔进了雪河。
Joanna Messina's body was found two months later by unsuspecting highway maintenance workers. She was still wrapped in her sleeping bag, which had since become moldy. Two 22 caliber bullets were retrieved from her remains. More than a year later on Monday, November 16, 1981, Sherry Morrow was bidding her boyfriend farewell. It was 11.30pm and he had just dropped Sherry off at work. For the past three years, the 23-year-old had been working as a topless dancer at various clubs throughout Anchorage's Tenderloin district. That night, she had a shift at the Wild Sherry on East Fourth Avenue. At some point during the night, the five-foot-six, blonde-haired and blue-eyed Sherry caught the eye of a male patron.
两个月后，毫不知情的公路养护工发现了乔安娜·梅西那的尸体。她仍然裹在睡袋里，而睡袋此时已经发霉了。从她的遗骸中取出了两颗.22口径的子弹。一年多后的1981年11月16日星期一，谢莉·莫罗正与男友告别。当时是晚上11点30分，男友刚把谢莉送到工作地点。在过去的三年里，这位23岁的姑娘一直在安克雷奇田德loin地区的各个俱乐部担任无上装舞者。那天晚上，她在第四大道东侧的“狂野谢莉”俱乐部有一场班次。夜里某个时候，这位身高五英尺六英寸、金发碧眼的谢莉引起了一位男性顾客的注意。
After work, Sherry went to her friend Lisa's house. She spoke of having met a male photographer at the Wild Sherry, who had offered to pay her $300 to pose nude for a photo shoot. As Sherry was quiet and shy, it didn't seem like the kind of thing she would want to do. But, Lisa knew her friend was also lonely and somewhat gullible. Lisa warned that only jerks visited the clubs, but this didn't dissuade Sherry from agreeing to do the photo shoot. The next morning, Sherry pulled on her baby blue-colored ski jacket over her sweater and a pair of dark blue moon boots over her jeans. Then she headed to a cafe several blocks from her workplace, where she had planned to meet the photographer. Not long after she had arrived there, a frightened Sherry was blindfolded and handcuffed in the photographer's car.
下班后，谢莉去了朋友丽莎的家。她谈到自己在“狂野谢莉”认识了一位男摄影师，对方提出付给她300美元，让她为一次摄影写真摆出全裸姿势。由于谢莉性格内向且害羞，这看起来并不像是她会愿意做的事。但是，丽莎知道她的朋友也很寂寞，而且有点轻信他人。丽莎警告说只有混蛋才会光顾那些俱乐部，但这并没有劝阻谢莉答应去拍写真。第二天早上，谢莉在毛衣外面套上了一件婴儿蓝色的滑雪夹克，并在牛仔裤外面穿了一双深蓝色的月亮靴。接着，她前往距离工作地点几个街区的一家咖啡馆，她原本计划在那里与摄影师会面。她到那儿不久后，惊恐万状的谢莉就在摄影师的车里被蒙上双眼并戴上了手铐。
He drove north along the Glen Highway, towards the sprawling Alaskan wilderness. Later that day, Sherry failed to show up to a doctor's appointment. Concerned, her boyfriend Dale retraced her last known movements. All of Sherry's belongings were still at her apartment. The only thing missing was a gold necklace with an arrowhead pendant that she always wore. Dale's search led to Lisa's house, where he was told about Sherry's plans to meet with the photographer. After failing to find Sherry, Dale informed Anchorage Police of her disappearance, but his worries fell on deaf ears. Police were aware that young women who worked in the Tenderloin District never really settled in the city and were known to move elsewhere without notice.
他驾驶着汽车沿着格伦公路向北行驶，驶向广袤无垠的阿拉斯加荒野。那天晚些时候，雪莉没能去参加一个医生的预约。她的男友戴尔感到很担心，于是沿着她最后已知行踪去找她。雪莉的所有物品依然留在公寓里。唯一不见的是一条她总是戴着的带箭头吊坠的金项链。戴尔的搜寻把线索指向了丽莎的家，在那里他得知了雪莉计划与摄影师会面的安排。在未能找到雪莉后，戴尔将她的失踪告知了安克雷奇警方，但他的担忧并没有引起重视。警方知道，在特伦德洛因区工作的年轻女性从来没有真正在这座城市安定下来，而且众所周知，她们往往会在没有通知的情况下搬到别处。
But Sherry had been looking forward to getting married and building her life in Anchorage. There was no discernible reason why she would abruptly and secretly relocate, essentially giving up on her dreams and relationship. Despite the police believing Sherry would reappear eventually, Dale remained worried. He visited the Anchorage Police Department almost weekly, begging officers to look for her. Gripping their firearms, John Daly and Doughty Holloway eyed their surroundings as the chilled waters of the Kinnick River flowed alongside them. The pair cut lonely figures against the glacial outcrops, snow-capped mountains, and dense forests of spruce and aspen. The lush green trees were in the process of changing to a vibrant shade of golden yellow, reflecting the onset of fall. It was Sunday, September 12, 1982, and John and Doughty were on the hunt.
但雪莉一直期盼着结婚并在安克雷奇建立自己的生活。没有任何明显的理由能解释她会突然且秘密地搬迁，这基本上等于放弃了她的梦想和恋情。尽管警方认为雪莉最终会重新出现，但戴尔依然忧心忡忡。他几乎每周都去安克雷奇警察局，恳求警官们寻找她的下落。约翰·戴利和多蒂·霍洛韦紧紧握着他们的枪，警惕地观察着周围的环境，冰冷的克尼克河水在他们身旁静静流淌。在冰川露头、白雪皑皑的山脉以及茂密的云杉和白杨森林的衬托下，这两个人显得格外孤寂。郁郁葱葱的树木正变成充满活力的金黄色，反映出秋天的来临。那是1982年9月12日，星期日，约翰和多蒂正在进行狩猎。
Escaping to the great outdoors was a welcome respite for John and Doughty. Both men were police officers stationed in the nearby city of Anchorage. Exploring the Kinnick River Valley about an hour's drive northeast was a much-needed change of scenery from their busy day-to-day lives. John and Doughty were avid trophy hunters and knew the valley well. That weekend they were hunting moose in a location so remote it was only accessible by off-road vehicles, boats, or planes. Trekking deep into the landscape was not easy, and its vastness meant it was rare to encounter any other people. John and Doughty weren't having much luck, and as the sun began to set over the horizon, the pair called it a day. They headed back towards their camp by cutting across a wide and long grey-pebbled sandbar that rose from the Kinnick River.
逃离喧嚣走向广阔的户外对于约翰和多蒂来说是一种令人欢迎的放松。这两名男子都是驻扎在附近城市安克雷奇的警察。探索大约向东北驱车一小时的克尼克河谷，给他们繁忙的日常工作带来了一种急需的景色变换。约翰和多蒂是热心的奖杯猎人，对山谷非常熟悉。那个周末，他们在一个极其偏远、只能通过全地形车、船只或飞机才能到达的地方猎鹿。深入这片广袤的风景并不容易，它的辽阔意味着很少能遇到其他人。约翰和多蒂运气不太好，随着太阳开始在地平线上落下，两人决定收工。他们穿过一条从克尼克河中升起、宽阔而漫长的灰色卵石沙洲，径直返回营地。
It was there that both men caught sight of a dark blue moon boot sticking out of the ground. Not far from the boot was a partially buried baby blue nylon ski jacket. The off-duty officers moved in for a closer look. In between the two items of clothing was a bone joint. The officers were conscious that they might have stumbled across a crime scene and backed away to avoid disturbing it. Night had almost fallen, and it was too dark to head back to Anchorage for help. Instead, they noted their location two miles downriver from the new Glen Highway Bridge and returned to their campsite with the intention to seek assistance at first light. As soon as dawn broke, John and Doughty made their way to a cabin and called the Alaska State Troopers, who had jurisdiction over the Kinnick River Valley region.
正是在那里，两人瞥见了一只从地里露出来的深蓝色月亮靴。离靴子不远的地方是一件半掩埋的浅蓝色尼龙滑雪夹克。这两名休班警察走近以便仔细查看。在这两件衣物之间是一个骨关节。警察们意识到他们可能偶然发现了一个犯罪现场，于是退后一步以免破坏现场。夜幕几乎已经降临，天色太黑，无法返回安克雷奇寻求帮助。相反，他们记下了距离新格伦公路桥下游两英里的位置，并返回了露营地，打算在天色刚亮时寻求援助。破晓刚过，约翰和多蒂就赶到了一间木屋，并打电话给对克尼克河谷地区拥有管辖权的阿拉斯加州骑警。
Officers from the Criminal Investigations Bureau met the two men by the skeletal remains. In the light of day, it was clear that the pair had stumbled across the badly decomposed body of a young woman. Although she lay close to the ground surface, it was obvious that she had been buried in a shallow grave. Dental records revealed the victim was Sherry Murrow, who had gone missing from Anchorage nine months earlier. An elastic bandage was wrapped around her head and over her eyes, pinned in place with metal clips. She had been shot three times in the back, but there were no bullet holes in her clothes. The troopers suspected her killer or killers had shot her while she was naked, then redressed her body. Found among Sherry's remains was a single shell casing from a two-to-three-colour bullet, a type of ammunition for high-powered semi-automatic rifles often used to kill large game.
来自刑事调查局的警官们在骨骸旁与这两名男子会合。在白天的光线下，很明显两人偶然发现了一具严重腐烂的年轻女性尸体。尽管她躺在接近地面的地方，但很明显她被埋在一个浅坑里。牙科记录显示受害者是雪莉·莫罗，她在九个月前从安克雷奇失踪。一条弹性绷带缠绕在她的头部并盖住眼睛，用金属夹固定在位。她的背部中了三枪，但衣服上没有弹孔。骑警们怀疑她的凶手在她赤身裸体时将她枪杀，然后再重新给尸体穿上衣服。在雪莉的遗骸中发现了一个两到三色子弹的单一弹壳，这是一种常用于杀死大型猎物的高威力半自动步枪弹药。
In the preceding months and years, the Tenderloin District became a black hole for many women who worked there. Dancers and sex workers alike were disappearing from the area without explanation. While the police brushed aside the concerns of their family and friends with the excuse that the women lived transient lifestyles, those who knew the women best suspected something was seriously amiss. Some of the missing worked at the same clubs, others were mothers who had left their young children behind. Nothing in any of their lives explained why the women would up and leave without getting in touch. 24-year-old Roxanne Eastland's roommate reported her missing in the first week of July 1980. Roxanne, who also went by the name Karen, had gone on a date with a man days earlier.
在之前的几个月和几年里，特伦德洛因区成了许多在那里工作的女性的黑洞。舞者和性工作者无缘无故地从该地区失踪。虽然警察以这些女性过着漂泊的生活方式为借口，对她们家人和朋友的担忧置之不理，但最了解这些女性的人怀疑有严重的问题发生了。一些失踪人员在同一家俱乐部工作，另一些则是留下幼儿的母亲。她们生活中的任何事情都无法解释为什么这些女性会在没有联系的情况下突然离开。24岁罗克珊·伊斯兰德的室友在1980年7月的第一周报告她失踪。罗克珊，也叫凯伦，几天前曾和一个男人约会过。
The pair had arranged to meet on Northern Lights Boulevard in downtown Anchorage. Roxanne never returned home. 41-year-old dancer Lisa Fertrell went to work at the Great Alaskan Bush Company Bar on the night of Saturday, September 6, 1980. Lisa, who carried a pistol in her purse for protection, vanished after her shift. Her roommates searched the Tenderloin District for her, but their questions rattled the local crime gangs, who warned that they might disappear too if their efforts brought police attention to the area. Undeterred, they reported Lisa as a missing person. 28-year-old Thai national Malay Larson was dancing to earn enough money to return home to Thailand.
两人原本安排在安克雷奇市中心的北极光大道见面。罗克珊再也没有回家。41岁的舞者丽莎·费特雷尔在1980年9月6日星期六的晚上去大阿拉斯加丛林公司酒吧上班。丽莎为了防身，在钱包里带了一把手枪，但在她下班后消失了。她的室友们在特伦德洛因区寻找她，但她们的询问惊动了当地的犯罪团伙，对方警告说，如果她们的努力引起了警方对该地区的关注，她们也可能会失踪。她们没有被吓退，而是将丽莎作为失踪人口上报。28岁的泰国公民马来·拉尔森正在跳舞，以赚取足够的钱返回泰国的家。
She disappeared from Anchorage in June 1981. 23-year-old Andrea Altieri was incredibly close to her roommate and dancing colleague Royale. The pair spent almost every day of their two-year-long friendship together. So, when Andrea disappeared on December 2, 1981, Royale knew her friend, affectionately known as Fish, wouldn't just abandon her without a proper goodbye. Royale was aware that Andrea had gone to meet an older man that day, who had offered to take her on a shopping spree at the local mall. The disappearances continued into 1982.
她在1981年6月从安克雷奇失踪。23岁的安德烈亚·阿尔蒂耶里与她的室友兼舞蹈同事罗亚尔关系极其亲密。她们两年的友谊中几乎每天都在一起。因此，当安德烈亚在1981年12月2日失踪时，罗亚尔知道她的朋友（被亲切地称为“鱼”）绝不会在没有好好告别的情况下就抛弃她。罗亚尔知道安德烈亚那天去见了一个年长的男人，他曾主动提出带她在当地的商场疯狂购物。失踪事件一直延续到1982年。
Sue Luna's older sister, Bobby, had been highly protective of her ever since they were kids. She warned 22-year-old Sue of the growing danger to dancers in the Tenderloin District and wanted her to arm herself with a small firearm. But the gentle and soft-hearted Sue declined. As she was deathly afraid of guns. Sue was rusted on to work at the Good Times Bar the night of Monday, May 24. During her shift, a man approached Sue and introduced himself as a photographer. He asked her to participate in a shoot for the following day, offering her $300.
苏·卢娜的姐姐鲍比从小就对她极其保护。她警告22岁的苏，特伦德洛因区对舞者的危险日益增加，并希望她配备一把小手枪。但温柔心软的苏拒绝了，因为她对枪支有着致命的恐惧。苏在5月24日星期一晚上被排班在好时光酒吧工作。在她值班期间，一个男人走近苏并自我介绍说自己是一名摄影师。他邀请她参加第二天的一次拍摄，并向她提供300美元。
Sue accepted the job and was never seen again. 20-year-old Tammy Peterson didn't enjoy dancing in Anchorage. For Tammy, dancing was an art form and she preferred crafting choreographed routines and designing her own costumes. Anchorage's dancing scene was a lot sleazier than Tammy anticipated. Despite this, she persisted in making the city her home. On August 7, Tammy called her parents to talk about her relationship woes. The following week, she vanished without a trace. Her family flew to Anchorage and underwent a desperate, though futile, search.
苏接受了这份工作，之后就再也没有被看到过。20岁的塔米·佩特森并不喜欢在安克雷奇跳舞。对塔米来说，舞蹈是一门艺术，她更喜欢设计编排动作和自己的服装。安克雷奇的舞蹈界比塔米预期的要低级得多。尽管如此，她还是坚持把这座城市当作自己的家。8月7日，塔米给父母打电话，谈论她的感情烦恼。第二周，她就消失得无影无踪。她的家人飞往安克雷奇，展开了一场绝望却徒劳的搜寻。
22-year-old Teresa Watson, known by friends as Nicole, arrived in the city in January 1983. On Saturday, March 26, Nicole's roommate visited the police station and pushed to file a missing persons report. Nicole had been dropped off at a local restaurant the afternoon prior, where she had planned to meet a man. She had described him as real nice and said he had promised to pay her $300 if she'd have lunch and spend an hour with him. 24-year-old Angela Fadden was reported missing by the owner-operator of a bar called Murphy's Law. He hadn't seen Angela for three months when he contacted authorities on Wednesday, May 25. The pair last spoke in late February when Angela mentioned having met a doctor. She described him as very ugly, but noted that he carried a big role of money.
22岁的特蕾莎·沃森，朋友们叫她妮可，于1983年1月来到这座城市。3月26日星期六，妮可的室友来到警察局，催促提交失踪人口报告。妮可前一天下午被送到当地一家餐馆，她原计划在那里见一个男人。她形容他非常好，并说他承诺如果她陪他吃午饭并花一个小时，就会付给她300美元。24岁的安吉拉·法登被一家名为“墨菲定律”的酒吧的业主兼经理上报失踪。当他在5月25日星期三联系当局时，他已经三个月没见到安吉拉了。两人最后一次交谈是在2月底，当时安吉拉提到她遇到了一位医生。她形容他非常丑，但指出他随身携带一大卷钱。
Angela, who also engaged in sex work, mentioned the doctor had offered her $300 for her services. Paula Goulding's last dance took place on Sunday, April 24, 1983 at the great Alaskan Bush Company. Although she was new to this line of work, the 30-year-old was very enthusiastic about it. After descending from the stage, she was approached by a man carrying a large roll of bills. The next morning, Paula waited for him at a local shopping mall where he had promised to spend several hundred dollars on her. According to the book Fair Game, he pulled up in his car shortly after noon and called Paula over. She climbed into the passenger seat and after a short drive, the man pulled into a deserted parking lot. Within seconds, Paula was being held at gunpoint as the man warned her.
安吉拉也从事性工作，她提到这位医生为她的服务提供了300美元。宝拉·古尔丁的最后一次舞蹈是在1983年4月24日星期日在大阿拉斯加丛林公司。尽管她是这行的新人，但这位30岁的女子对此非常热情。从舞台下来后，一个拿着一大卷钞票的男人走近她。第二天早上，宝拉在当地的一家购物中心等他，他曾承诺在那里为她花几百美元。根据《公平猎物》一书的记载，他在中午过后不久将车开过来，把宝拉叫了过去。她爬上了副驾驶座，在短暂的车程后，这个男人驶入了一个荒凉的停车场。几秒钟之内，宝拉就被枪口指着，那名男子警告她。
Now, you'll do just what I say. I'm good at this. Done it lots of times before. Later that day, the pilot of a lightweight aircraft was soaring low over the Canick River when he caught sight of something below. It was a blue and white two-seater Super Cub airplane parked on a gravel sandbar. Making big, sweeping turns, the pilot circled above the Super Cub three times, looking out for any sign of life. It was not unusual to spotlight aircraft within the valley. Off-road ground vehicles tended to get stuck in the bush, so it was quicker and easier to fly in. On his third flyover, the pilot spotted a lone man standing by the Super Cub. The man looked up at the pilot and waved at him in a friendly manner.
现在，你要完全听我的。我很擅长这个。以前做过很多次了。那天晚些时候，一架轻型飞机的飞行员在卡尼克河上空低空飞行时，瞥见了下方的东西。那是一架停在砾石沙洲上的蓝白相间的双座超级小熊飞机。飞行员做了几个巨大的清扫转弯，在超级小熊上方盘旋了三次，寻找任何生命迹象。在该山谷中用聚光灯照飞机并不罕见。全地形地面车辆往往会陷入丛林中，因此飞进去更快更容易。在他的第三次飞越中，飞行员发现了一个独自站在超级小熊旁的男子。那个人抬头看着飞行员，友善地向他挥了挥手。
In return, the pilot performed a wing dip, the flight equivalent of waving a hand. Thinking nothing more of the encounter, the pilot steered downriver and out of sight. As the sound of the plane's engine faded into the distance, the man on the ground breathed the sigh of relief. Grateful and lucky that it hadn't landed. Once the coast was clear, he reached into his Super Cub and pulled out his .223 caliber Ruger Mini-14 rifle. Then he headed back into a nearby patch of woodland where an old meat shack was tucked away. The abandoned building had once been used by hunters to store and hang game. But on this occasion, it contained Paula Goulding restrained to an iron pipe.
作为回应，飞行员做了一个机翼倾斜动作，这相当于飞行的挥手致意。飞行员没有多想这次相遇，驾机向下游驶去，消失在视野之外。随着飞机引擎的轰鸣声渐渐消失在远方，地上的男子松了一口气。他庆幸飞机没有降落，真是又感激又幸运。一旦确定安全，他便伸手进超级小熊机舱，拿出了他的.223口径鲁格Mini-14步枪。然后他回到了附近的一片树林里，那里藏着一间旧肉屋。这座废弃的建筑曾被猎人用来储存和悬挂猎物。但在这次，里面关着被绑在一根铁管上的宝拉·古尔丁。
The man had taken to flying into the valley in his own personal airplane as opposed to fewer risks. Cars left tire tracks that led to his remote hunting ground and the graves of his victims. His plane took him directly to its center, getting him in and out without a trace. On each occasion, he'd take off from Merrill Field in Anchorage, a public use general aviation airport one mile east of downtown. He'd soar high above where any local air traffic control tower could identify him. Nestled in a small space behind his seat would be his handcuffed captive, unable to move. He'd fly northward into the depths of the Canick River Valley and bring the Super Cub down on the wide, flat sandbar that acted as a runway. Once it came to a stop, he'd retrieve his frightened captive.
为了降低风险，这个男人开始乘坐他自己的私人飞机飞入山谷。汽车留下的轮胎痕迹会通往他偏远的狩猎场和受害者的坟墓。他的飞机直接带他到达中心，让他无声无息地进出。每次，他都会从安克雷奇的梅里尔机场起飞，这是一个位于市中心以东一英里处的公共通用航空机场。他会高高飞过任何当地空中交通管制塔台能识别他的高度。在他座位后方的一个小空间里，会蜷缩着戴上手铐的俘虏，无法动弹。他会向北飞入卡尼克河谷的深处，并将超级小熊降落在作为跑道的宽阔平坦的沙洲上。一旦飞机停下，他就会去取他那惊恐的俘虏。
She was confronted with the vast, foreign landscape around her. The expansive gravel sandbar, the meandering river, the distant mountains, and the patches of dense woodland. Hidden among the trees was the old meat shack. Friday, September 2, 1983 marked the beginning of the Labor Day weekend and two teenagers were spending the holiday moose hunting in the Canick River Valley. It was approaching 1pm when the pair passed a derelict meat shack in the woods before emerging along the river. As they made their way across a large sandbar, they spotted human bones nestled in the earth. Authorities descended on the area. The bones were found along the same sandbar where Sherry Morrow's remains were discovered almost a year earlier.
她面对的是周围广阔而陌生的风景。广袤的砾石沙洲、蜿蜒的河流、远处的山脉以及片片密林。树木掩映之中是那间旧肉屋。1983年9月2日星期五标志着劳动节长假期的开始，两个青少年在卡尼克河谷度过假期进行猎鹿。接近下午1点时，两人经过了树林中的一间废弃肉屋，然后出现在河边。当他们穿过一个大沙洲时，他们发现了泥土中夹杂着的人类骨骼。当局涌入该地区。这些骨骼是在几乎一年前发现雪莉·莫罗遗骸的同一片沙洲沿线被发现的。
Dental records confirmed that this newly recovered body was 30-year-old Paula Goulding. A dancer based in Anchorage, Paula had vanished four months earlier following a shift at the Great Alaskan Bush Company. She was still wearing the outfit she was last seen in, though it was in a state of disarray. Her jeans were unzipped and her sweater was torn in half down at the front, as was her bra. Paula had been shot in the back just as Sherry Morrow had been, the fatal bullet passing through her heart. Her clothes, like Sherry's, featured no bullet holes. Lying near her body was a spent .223 caliber shell casing. Ballistics confirmed that it had come from the same firearm as the bullet used to murder Sherry Morrow.
牙科记录确认这具新找回的尸体是30岁的宝拉·古尔丁。作为一名在安克雷奇工作的舞者，宝拉在大阿拉斯加丛林公司值班四个月前失踪了。她仍然穿着她最后一次被看到时的衣服，尽管已经凌乱不堪。她的牛仔裤拉链没拉，毛衣和胸罩在前面都被撕成两半。宝拉和雪莉·莫罗一样背部中枪，致命的子弹穿过了她的心脏。她的衣服和雪莉的一样，没有弹孔。躺在她尸体附近的是一个用过的.223口径弹壳。弹道学证实它来自与谋杀雪莉·莫罗的子弹相同的武器。
Both Sherry and Paula had worked in Anchorage's Tenderloin District, as had a Clutner Annie, the unidentified woman whose remains were found in 1980 near a Clutner Lake. The lake was reached via the Glen Highway, which led to the Kinnick River a little further north. Then there was Joanna Messina, whose bullet-riddled body was found south of Anchorage, near the Harbour City of Seward. She too engaged in sex work. Although Annie had been stabbed to death, and Joanna wasn't from Anchorage, the four crime scenes and victim profiles were far too similar for their murders to be mere coincidences. It was now abundantly clear that a serial killer was active in Anchorage, targeting vulnerable and sometimes destitute women. He appeared to choose this kind of victim as he knew the police would be less inclined to search for them. Pouring over missing persons reports from the Tenderloin District exposed the killer's pattern.
雪莉和宝拉都曾在安克雷奇的特伦德洛因区工作过，1980年在克卢特纳湖附近发现遗骸的身份不明女性克卢特纳·安妮也是如此。通过格伦公路可以到达该湖，该公路通往更北一点的克尼克河。还有乔安娜·梅西纳，她的布满弹孔的尸体在安克雷奇南部被发现，靠近海港城市苏厄德。她也从事性工作。虽然安妮是被刺身亡，而且乔安娜不是来自安克雷奇，但四个犯罪现场和受害者特征实在太相似了，她们的谋杀绝不仅仅是巧合。现在已经非常清楚，安克雷奇有一个活跃的连环杀手，专门针对脆弱甚至贫困的女性。他似乎选择这种类型的受害者，因为他知道警察不太愿意寻找她们。仔细研究特伦德洛因区的失踪人口报告，揭示了凶手的作案模式。
He'd meet his victim in a bar or on the street, luring her in with offers of work, money or gifts. Judging by the amount of women who had vanished under these circumstances in recent years, his kill count could already be in the double digits. In an effort to generate a suspect profile, Sergeant Glenn Flothe of the Alaska State Troopers reached out to one of the foremost authorities on serial murderers. The FBI's Behavioral Science Unit, also known as BSU. Established in the early 1970s following a sharp increase in sexual assaults and homicides, the BSU worked to understand the minds and behaviors of serial offenders. By doing so, they hoped they would be better equipped to apprehend criminals and prevent future crimes. As detailed in the book Butcher Baker by authors Walter Gilmore and Leland Hale, Flothe spoke with BSU agent Roy Hazelwood. Hazelwood, who had been at the centre of the unit since its inception, listened attentively as he was told about each crime scene, the victims and how they had been killed.
他会在酒吧或街头与受害者见面，用工作、金钱或礼物的诱惑引诱她。从近年来在这些情况下失踪的女性数量来看，他的杀人数量可能已经达到两位数。为了生成嫌疑人侧写，阿拉斯加州骑警队的格伦·弗洛斯中警官联系了连环杀人案领域的最高权威之一。联邦调查局的行为科学部，也被称为BSU。该部门成立于20世纪70年代初，此前性侵犯和凶杀案急剧增加，BSU致力于了解连环犯罪分子的心理和行为。通过这样做，他们希望能够更好地装备自己来抓捕罪犯并防止未来的犯罪。正如作家沃尔特·吉尔摩和雷兰·黑尔在《屠夫面包师》一书中所详述的那样，弗洛斯与BSU特工罗伊·黑泽尔伍德进行了交谈。黑泽尔伍德自该部门成立以来就一直在核心位置，他专心听取了关于每个犯罪现场、受害者以及她们如何被杀害的描述。
After pausing for a moment to reflect, Agent Hazelwood said the killer was most likely between the ages of 33 and 44. There was a chance he had a history of arson or shoplifting, maybe even both. He would be of above average intelligence, probably a well-known and respected member of the community, who might have ties to a local business. Someone you wouldn't look at twice. But beneath his apparent success would be a darker history. He'd experienced social rejection during his adolescence, low self-esteem, insecure with women, most likely spoke with a speech impediment. An avid outdoorsman, his use of isolated locations and high-powered weaponry indicated he was a hunter. This hobby appeared to play a major part in his crimes.
在停顿片刻进行反思后，黑泽尔伍德特工表示，凶手的年龄很可能在33岁到44岁之间。他很有可能有纵火或入店行窃的历史，甚至可能两者兼有。他将具有高于平均水平的智力，可能是一个知名且受人尊敬的社区成员，可能与当地企业有联系。一个你不会看第二眼的人。但在他明显的成功背后，会有更黑暗的历史。他在青春期经历过社会拒绝，自卑，对女性不安全感，很可能说话有语言障碍。作为一个狂热的户外活动爱好者，他对偏远地区和高威力武器的使用表明他是一个猎人。这个爱好似乎在他的犯罪中扮演了重要角色。
With each new victim, his kills had become less abrupt and more methodical. He went from carrying out quick and disorganised murders just outside of the city to taking his captives deep into the untamed wilderness, where he stripped them naked, had them run and then gunned them down as if they were his prey. Within the large amount of paperwork that had accumulated in the case was a sealed manila envelope. Tearing it open, Sergeant Glenn Flothey found a report inside. It had been put together by an officer Greg Baker of Anchorage PD's sexual assault unit and detailed a harrowing incident that occurred earlier that year. Robert Yount had an early start on the morning of Monday, June 13, 1983. By 5am, the 36-year-old truck driver was on the road in Anchorage, heading west along East Fifth Avenue between the Seward and Glenn Highways. He was passing Merrill Field when all of a sudden, a barefooted young woman raced out from the airport grounds and into the path of Robert's truck.
随着每一个新受害者的出现，他的杀戮变得不那么突兀而更有条理。他从在城市郊区进行快速、混乱的谋杀，转变为将俘虏带到未开化的荒野深处，在那里他剥去她们的衣服，让她们逃跑，然后像猎物一样将她们枪杀。在这起案件中积累的大量文件中，有一个密封的马尼拉信封。格伦·弗洛斯中警官撕开它，在里面发现了一份报告。该报告由安克雷奇警察局性侵犯部门的格雷格·贝克警官编写，详细记录了当年早些时候发生的一起令人心碎的事件。罗伯特·容特在1983年6月13日星期一的早晨很早就开始工作。到早上5点，这位36岁的卡车司机已经在安克雷奇的路上，沿着东第五大道向西行驶，介于苏厄德公路和格伦公路之间。他正经过梅里尔机场，突然，一个赤脚的年轻女性从机场地面冲出来，跑进罗伯特的卡车路径。
He hit the brakes as the woman spun to face his oncoming vehicle. She held her arms up in the air. Her wrists were handcuffed. Help me, she screamed. To be continued next week. Thank you for watching. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他踩下刹车，女人旋转着面向他迎面而来的车辆。她把双臂举在空中。她的手腕戴着手铐。救救我，她尖叫道。下周未完待续。感谢观看。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。